you guys doing good
I am in a great mood my dad has turned
70 which is exciting because it means
I'm now in a house soon not easy to do
in California man what are you supposed
to get your parents when they get that
old I got my dad nothing and then he was
like where's my gift I was like dirty
lost that watch he's like what watch
it's like we got to get you to the
hospital I'm not a lot of old people
lately in fact last month I opened up
for a legendary Spanish singer named
Julio Iglesias how about that guys
I did not know who that was thought my
agent and misspelled Enrique I don't
know what the hell was going on but
we're - oh I've ever done who heals a
manager takes me sad he goes listen
Hootie likes to go up when he likes to
go up so we give you the signal you
bring him up you don't even finish your
joke I'm like dude that's gonna be
awkward depend on what joke I'm in the
middle of doing all right like what if
I'm like oh man the worst part but
having crabs is Julio Iglesias and Julio
did the most insane thing I have ever
seen anyone do during a show and I swear
to god this really happened he's on
stage front of 3,000 people who heels
dancing not like this but just go with
it he points at his trumpet player he
says this man is gay all right that's
better than those 3,000 people react he
goes I could never be gay because I like
women and everyone's like alright well
that's how sexuality works Julio and it
goes but if I was gay this man would be
my lover
that's just a very gay thing to say and
then he just kept the show movie like
how crazy is that right
so after as I go through the Trump Blair
swear - gotta go dude that's like a
really weird bit do you guys do that
every week the guy goes no I'm not gay
this food held up his wedding ring and
goes Julio's are so bored of Turin at
this point he says random stuff about us
during the show he goes yes a doctor
says you're gay now he says he's banging
your wife and that's when I became a
huge Julio Iglesias fan your boss doing
that attention everybody
Johnson's gay I wasn't banging Becky I'd
be hitting that get back to work
that's been a weird year for Julio and
they got my chest waxed those things
aren't necessarily connected but I think
they might as well be I I had to get
waxed cuz my girlfriend of four years
pointed out that the whole time we've
been dating I have been gross because
they have a lot of Jewish chest hair and
I think we have sex my neck goes in and
it looks like a rabbis face I think and
I'm sweating so it's like a rabbi does
another yeah just so-so I just said why
she asked I didn't like the way she did
it she goes yes it'll hurts but the pain
you feel will be worth out turned on
tonight will be you know it's like I
think you just used my own anal sex
speech against me
and that's the story of Hanukkah now I I
did I went and got wax I went to a place
in LA called wax that's a pretty benign
name for how that feels how about the
fall accost that's the more accurate
description cuz it hurts dude when she
did the first I thought something had
gone wrong oh my god well it can't be
meant to feel like this would not be a
viable business plan yes here's like
they stay calm waxers right they're like
she was like a ninja she's like so how
was your weekend I was like I'll tell
you where bin Laden is like it's
freaking out
and it's a weird porn my relations
because I decide that I do not want to
have children
cuz I realized you can have such a loser
for a kid you ever think about that like
you really don't get to pick like a
uterus is like a Yahtzee Cup you're just
kind of that's what I got out of there
really I got the kid who holds the
mattress sale sign that's my kids that's
got to be the worst kid to have right
you got a lie about them Jeremy works in
advertising is this can't pick your kid
dude what if my kid wants I mean that
frat guy you're like dyes his hair
blonde wears a seashell necklace lasts
like this does that thing I owe them
every day just Paul shut up Trevor damn
it why did I name you that and we all
have the same concern right that your
kid winds up being a pedophile
or a white person that acts black we all
have the same
it's not a black joke it's a very
specific white joke go to Long Beach
take some notes I know it gets weird to
talk about race right like the other day
I very innocently asked my Japanese
friend if he speaks Japanese even that
got weird he goes moe I don't even speak
Chinese
turns out he's my Chinese friend I don't
know dude like this man is gay there's
Rena i'm mo mandel
you